Okay. So you just heard a little bit about this product already, but I will
kind of highlight what I think is really important. So yesterday you heard me talk
about why community oncology can do by specifics, right? So I'm going to up the ante a little bit
more and talk about moving CAR-T cell therapies into the community setting. So don't everybody
take a breath at once. So why should CAR-T be cruising into the community? Again, I'm not saying
all of community, okay? I mean, but there are a lot of sites that can potentially do this. And
why? So is this suitable for sites with robust by specific programs and who are doing a lot of
clinical trials? You know, we know that there's improved safety of various products against not
one size fits all. And there have been alterations in factor cardination to alleviate some of the
stressors in the community. But we know more patients need access to product and the ability
to receive. We know that the amount of patients that are in the community that are in the community
actually getting to CAR-T, you know, is dismal, right? 15 to 20%, depending on the data that
you're looking at. And all of these patients, for the most part, you know, are residing in the
community. And so many patients are not being referred for one reason or another. So how do
we improve on this? You know, and I wonder, you know, are our by specifics paving the way,
you know, to serve as a bridge to community oncology being able to do CAR-T?
So with that, you know, we already kind of briefly heard a little bit about the
But this is the Phase 1B study for Paracel, you know, looking at patients with relapsed refractory
B-cell lymphoma. And I'm not going to go through all of this again. But I am going to highlight,
you know, a few things that I think are really, really important from this study,
if the clicker works. And I'm going to really focus on the fixed dose. So the recommended
Phase 2 dose, which is at 75 million. Again, we talked about the baseline characteristics a few
years ago. So this is a really well balanced between the all doses group and then the, you
know, the 75 million CAR-T cell group. These patients, you know, again, 70% were male, you
know, a large amount of them had advanced disease. So I think it's important to note this is a high,
you know, a higher risk population. But what I want to focus on, which is really important to me
as a community oncologist, is the, you know, RP2D, you know, section here with CRS, right? So yes,
if you look at grade three, grade four, there's zero. And that is really, really important when
I'm thinking about, you know, doing a CAR-T product in the community. Again, these are these
agents, just like bispecifics are not all the same. And I think it's important to think about
that. Most of the common TAEs were cytopenias and CRS. 20% of the patients in that RP2D group
reported serious treatment emergent AEs. And there were six deaths on study, but due to
COVID-19, not all of them reported serious treatment. So again, you know, we just heard about there were a few grade three events in that all doses group. But when looking at that, those 25 patients in the RP2D group, again, we'll see here, yes, CRS is occurring, but a majority of these are grade one. And again, no grade three, grade four events. I mean, and that's better than some of our bispecifics. So I think it's important to note that some of these agents actually, you know, again, we have to be well aware of them and respect them, but can't
potentially be done in the community. So ICANNs, yes, there were events, but you know, very few. Again, it's an only an N of 25 in the study, right, but but showing that, you know, that the safety does seem to be there. And this may be the product that can be used in the community. Overall response, obviously, very, very impressive, both in that the RP2D group, as well as the all doses group. And then also, you know, looking over at the line of therapy. So
we always talk about sequencing, when should we be using CAR-T, I mean, I guess this, you know, further enhances that, you know, really, if patients are eligible for CAR-T, they should be going for CAR-T cell therapy. And that second line, again, small population, we need to see how, you know, the data pans out, but definitely impressive when thinking about this product. Again, we just heard, you know, really promising results, you see the dark green lines representing the complete responders, really exciting, again, highlighting that our people
with the RP2D dose with the median follow up of four months, you know, time to CR was one month, the duration of response three months or greater was 79%, and five responses deepened from PR to CR. So in conclusion, this shows a safety efficacy, and the pharmacokinetic profile of the 75 million, that's the RP2D dose of the bicarb with priceless L. And at that recommended dose, there were no gray three, three, four CRS to date. And
this shows a safety efficacy, and the pharmacokinetic profile of the 75 million, that's the RP2D dose of the bicarb with priceless L. And at that recommended dose, there were no gray three, three, four CRS to date. And
this shows a safety efficacy, and the pharmacokinetic profile of the 75 million, that's the RP2D dose of the bicarb with priceless L. And at that recommended dose, there were no gray three, three CRS to date. And
- Thank you.